welcome back to new rockstars i'm erik
voss a new loki trailer is here and as a
marvel timeline psycho who has spent
half his timeline in dmvs
i'm low-key losing my [ __ ] over the show
so i'm gonna break down all the easter
eggs and visual clues i found to try to
solve this rubik's cube of a series here
we go
i know what this place is
loki is detained by the tva the time
variance authority marvel's time
enforcement agency
this agent is hunter b-15 played by
wunmi mosaku
who appears later in the trailer with a
machete in a setting that looks similar
at least to the blue
carved surfaces of juttenheim home of
the frost giants which if you think
about it 2012 loki as the son of frost
giant laffy
might have teleported too definitely
rather than a place like asgard which he
had just failed to steal the throne of
and notice how b15s holding the
tesseract so this
is shortly after loki's escaping
avengers end game when he snatched the
tesseract during the time heist in 2012
and fled into
this new branch timeline in which he
never died in infinity war
but also he never grew his relationship
with thor in the dark world or in thor
ragnarok so that's the loki we're
dealing with here
still kind of an [ __ ] i guess he's
always been still kind of an [ __ ]
that's why we love him but listen
closely to how this portal opens
yeah a little thing on the end there
kind of like an elevator arriving on a
floor
the december trailer showed a tva
elevator with its bizarrely labeled
buttons
which could represent how these tva
agents are moving through these
different points
before we even get to that the wall
tiles are ocd torture
sometimes lining up as circles sometimes
arranged as
waves sometimes but but but but
pick a lane tiles this orange nightmare
is already an
apt metaphor for the show with its own
color palette of like sea foam and tan
and orange all in this over complicated
rubik's cube configuration that just by
sliding and twisting a bit would all
line up perfectly
but it never will and that's what loki
is and we see this concept as well with
the loki title card with its switching
letter typefaces
some of which if you were to put some
effort into it could match up in a way
so that they're all wooden or
all emerald but like loki they are a
kind of shapeshifter impossible to pin
down now i love this
at this check-in desk in the tva is a
skrull
in a tracksuit so in addition to
squirrels showing up in spider-man far
from home and in one division another
scroll
is a time fugitive now i don't think
this scroll is any important scroll
you know like that missing fourth
squirrel on earth who got away in
captain marvel this could just be
marvel's way of planting skrulls
everywhere in the universe to set up the
secret invasion series which i think is
gonna come next year and we get this
slightly wider shot of tva hq
actually on the bottom right and on the
bottom left you can see tva
archives because the tva as we see in
the trailer is
way bigger and way more elaborate it's
actually beautiful
but these floors in particular are where
they keep all their records actually in
those elevators you can see
not people but stacks of boxes that
these archivists are likely sending from
florida florida to pass the paperwork
around and then of course these three
huge statues these are the time keepers
actually more on them in the next
section
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart
i am smart i know okay okay
okay here loki actually mentions the
time keepers by name now the timekeepers
are the three figures enshrined all over
the tva
in the archives room in the courtroom in
the judges quarters
in the comics the timekeepers were
created by someone known as he who
remains
the final tva agent at the end of all
time he created them in order to teach
the next universal cycle how to
avoid the errors of the past also kind
of as living batteries that store
chronal
energy that tba retirees use it's fun
and ridiculous
but here in the courtroom the center
timekeeper's head looks a little similar
to kang the conqueror who will be coming
into the mcu played by jonathan majors
and ant-man and the wasp quantomania
kang is a time traveling villain and
really public enemy number one in the
tva like where the tva comes into the
marvel world
kang is there kang has multiple
iterations of himself in a dynasty
across multiple timelines building a
time empire that he calls chronopolis
which i've actually theorized could be
that hidden city in the quantum realm
and i'm thinking in the mcu kang may
actually be
a former time keeper now these golden
doors are covered in hourglass shapes
and this
is probably the tva logo it's in the
crest that you can see in the courtroom
wall and on the bullpen floor it's a
shield with laurels actually to the left
the va
letters are really inverted mirror
shapes of each other so if you were to
stack them
top to top it would form that hourglass
now to the right of the mural are the
time keepers again
and above the words for all time always
which could be the agency motto now loki
is brought before time court three
google bought the raw's character
reported to be judge ravona rinslayer
an object of affection of kang the
conqueror who once tried to annex her
home as part of his time
empire and fittingly notices her head is
positioned directly
in the lips of that time keeper i think
it looks a lot like kang now this
courtroom has murals of chrono monitors
both the cops and the clerks and the
civil servants
one of those is owen wilson's character
sitting behind them named mobius
immobius a word that we have heard an
end game when tony stark cracked the
code for time travel
this time in the shape of a mobius strip
inverted please then a classic dmv style
room with pointless empty stanchions
like if no one's in line why do you got
to set them up make me weave through all
of them another detainees comedian josh
fadom who with this hair
does look a bit similar to loki maybe
even an alternate version of him
a couple posters in the back of this
room one shows an eye but then the other
ones there's this oran cartoon clock
stomping on another clock warning behave
or you'll get your clock cleaned
this little shows up later on the tv
screens and that
is his face at the bottom of the
elevator buttons i assume he
is kind of a tva mascot a symbol a
maddening little orange nightmare
in loki's otherwise green and golden
world in the 2-5
time theater it's another orange
nightmare that haunts loki a projector
that shows loki's in-game escape and in
the past trailer his defeat by the
avengers and your savior is here moment
in ragnarok and based on loki's
uncomfortable grinch his death and
infinity war
the way his life should have played out
in an alternate history the history
we've known next clip
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
okay this tva transcriber has a cat
who's also on his mug but notice how it
sees loki
could this creature actually be a
flircan i mean it's more likely for a
tva agent to have a flurk
than an earth cat and when loki doesn't
comply it could open its jaws of terror
behind this guy is a clock with an
insane number of hands
of course all of loki's spoken words
print out on a dot matrix printer with
paper hanging from above like toilet
paper you'd think there'd be
way more for someone like loki who's
over a thousand years old but hey maybe
they're just setting up a joke
like oh this is just what you've said
this week and the printout lists loki as
variant
l1130 which must be the tva designation
for this variant loki because remember
the prime mcu loki is a corpse floating
somewhere in space
like all those letters and its title
logo the paperwork also lists time
status tva0152783
and 5273.02 is the time code for
this is absurd and mobius told us in the
last trailer that time works differently
here so maybe that five digit number is
the
increment of time all of this is
happening in on to the next clip
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it okay here
in the chrono monitor bullpen is a
screen
showing the time stream which mobis
calls the proper flow
of time that now splits into chaos
thanks to loki's move in endgame
but mobius's words echo how the ancient
one described this using a similar
visual in in-game
the infinity stones create what you
experience as the flow of time
remove one of the stones and that close
splits
now the avengers did all kinds of
meddling to the flow of time and end
game but presumably off-screen captain
america returned all the stones from
where they were taken but the one
infinity stone created branch he would
have been unable to restore was loki
escaping with the space stone in the
tesseract other screens show the orange
demon clock trapped in the bars of a
coco clock
monitors labeled a12 a10 maybe referring
to different timelines that are frozen
in stasis until they can sort all this
out
interesting how from the timeline
there's the branch in the middle
extending out the furthest it's probably
for loki's escape and in-game but there
are other branches that
branch out after this in the timeline
but also before this in the timeline
that means loki's variance caused future
time disturbances but
also caused some in the past behind it
which means that some of those future
events must have
looped back to the past behind loki
causing disruptions there
maybe a clue that loki inadvertently led
to a future time villain like kang
disrupting things at all points in
history and notice how on this grid
parallel lines depict the deviation from
the mean that it would be safe for those
lines to skew with the red lines on
either side
signaling the danger zone that these
broken branch histories
should not cross moving on i need your
unique loki perspective
do i get a weapon yeah
you really believe in this loki variant
ah clever wordplay from mobius there
unique low-key
perspective so why do they need loki
well notice how loki addresses them
makes it sound like he's been long aware
the tba
exists and he is a sorcerer he's
actually the wizard that falcon just
referenced so
that might make him more immune to the
effects of time hopping the chrono
monitors are armed with batons which i
compared to the sorcerer's staff of the
living tribunal they don't really look
it but this whole agency
are essentially wizards like loki well
according to sam wilson when they're not
wearing hats they're sorcerers
think about it but before we continue
special thanks to extra the world's
largest smartphone wallet brand for
sponsoring this video
exeter designs the smartest wallets in
the world which you can track with their
solar-powered tracker worldwide so
whether you dropped your wallet while
swinging from webs around new york or if
it just slipped between your couch
cushions your tracker will help you find
it
instantly it's voice activated and solar
powered so two hours of sunshine give it
a three month charge
so i'm just gonna split the tracker in
my wallet download the chipolo app on
your phone and then you can ring your
wallet from your phone
or you can ring your phone from your
wallet here we go uh-oh where to put my
phone just gonna tap this button while
covering my street address so you can't
stalk me
and i hear an amazing arcade star little
diggling
how does this get over it there in
darla's mouth
you silly little doggie extra's slim
profile wallets are awesome they're made
of premium
leather they have rfid protection and
you can use this little button to fan
out your cards
wow so no more pawing through an
overstuffed grandpa wallet it's also
thin enough to not leave an unsightly
lump in your spandex spider suit
or your jeans i guess so check out these
wallets with the link below
and earn an additional discount with our
code extra.com
new rockstars so loki suits up with this
jacket with the tva crest and variant on
the back made it clear that he is a
timeline displaced detainee forced to
help them on this case
but what is this case what are they
doing where are they going who are they
chasing well first we see them entering
what looks like a wren fair you can
actually see a booth for festival maps
presumably the tva agents are invisible
to the locals as they do their
investigating their investigation might
have just led them here because there's
someone legitimately from renaissance
era england who is here and just
blending in everyone assumes they're
just really into character but they also
swarm this rocks card store it's spelled
with two
exes like the roxon corporation that has
shown up in the mcu
it's an energy conglomerate that now in
this timeline might have expanded into
retail like you know amazon jeff bezos
who's trying to take over the world and
make it so no one can unionize and
notice these school buses
we know from set photos these have rox
cart evacuation shuttle written on them
evacuation huh so it is storming really
hard it looks like we're in the midst of
a hurricane or a tornado
maybe a deadly storm was about to
destroy the shopping center and the time
bandit they were chasing was
here right before it was destroyed doing
something important the tva knows this
and now they're trying to close in on
them
in a kind of temporal pincer maneuver i
mean hey we also know that loki visits
pompeii
maybe there's something to natural
disasters destroying things so who is
that time bandit well there's this
hooded figure
fighting chrono monitors at those golden
doors in this rocks card store from
security screens this is sophia
dimartino's character still
unknown but believed to be either lady
loki who is an alternate female form of
loki in the comics after the ragnarok
event when his soul detaches from his
body and possesses a new female form
some are saying it could also be
enchantress sylvie lushton but the way
they keep referring to loki as a
variant to the norm i think the various
loki's we see
in this footage from president loki to
db cooper loki could all be alternate
timeline
variants and dimartino could be a lady
loki from yet another timeline
the most dangerous of the loki's
wreaking havoc across the time stream
and now the tva needs our loki to stop
the worst
of them next clip luckily he believes in
himself enough for the both of us
why it is adorable
that you think you could possibly
manipulate
me okay loki appears in the ruins of new
york city you can see avengers tower
behind him and what i believe to be the
aftermath of a timeline in which loki
was victorious in the battle of new york
we know the show is revisiting the
events of that avengers 2012 film
because the december trailer showed loki
once again with the scepter in front of
a specific mirror that was in tony
stark's penthouse at the top of that
tower in that film so i know endgame
already kind of did this but we could be
looking at like a double layer time
heist the avengers revisiting this
battle and in-game snoop in the
background saluting america's ass and
behind
them loki from this disney plus series
saluting asgard's ass
so this could be the timeline in which
that victorious loki runs for president
which is looking like a nod to the 2016
vote for loki comic and now our loki has
to face the forces of the smuggest
version of himself like we know there
are two loki's in this setting because
footage shows the tva suited loki
and that king loki is talking to someone
when he says
what did you expect yeah i don't think
he's breaking the fourth wall there he's
talking to
loki l1130 then de martino's hooded
character drags an unconscious crota
monitor to that time portal this looks
like actress sasha lane
c20 who shows up later fighting another
chrono monitor while holding a
jousting pole so this is likely that
wren faire setting and that could be the
reason the tva went there
next clip i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
all right here an apocalyptic setting
showing a shattered moon crashing into a
planet's surface
spewing down meteors upon what looks
like a camp with these orange tents
maybe a kind of work camp or a mining
camp
and a trailer shack marked with the
number 21.
in other shots loki finds dimartino's
character here and has a moment with her
and no for the melee time this character
is not natasha romanov on vermeer from
endgame no it's dimortino's character
i don't know why people keep saying that
i am wondering if this is the end of all
time a universe where the rules of
gravity no longer apply and planets and
moons are just crashing into each other
the only one left is dimartino
she who remains and she could be the one
who has the future connection with the
timekeepers and us with kang
then we see loki on this golden throne
which at first glance just looks like
the throne of asgard but this is not
exactly the throne of asgard it's been
altered its curved points at the top
show golden swans in places where odin's
ravens would perch
and from the armrests look like snakes
loki has a history with snakes
there's one time with real children he
he transformed himself into a snake and
he knows that i love snakes
so i went to pick up the snake to admire
it and he transformed back into himself
and he was like yeah it's me
and he stopped me and a deleted scene in
the first thor film
but one of the coolest looking settings
is this fortress with streaks cracked
into it like the whole thing was a pane
of glass that splintered loki has a
sword strapped to his back and later
dimartino's character
does some cool moves in this location
looks like a library with a fireplace
i am wondering if this could be kang's
lair in temporal limbo where the final
kang
kang prime sits alone at the end of all
time feeding off all the paradoxes that
other kangs have created for him then
more shots and president loki's lair
which contains the mythical real world
polybius arcade game i went into that in
my past trailer breakdown
like the whole db cooper thing it's one
of the urban myths that this show is
saying
loki was behind and loki uses green
sorcery in an attack the first time
we've seen his magic used like this it's
similar to the color wiggly woo energy
blast used by wanda maximoff and agatha
harkness another reminder that luki is a
sorcerer magic taught to him
by friega who was an asgardian witch or
is
now she's still alive in this timeline
then a quick shot of someone running
through this orange fogged eatery or a
bar it's got
futuristic writing looks pretty cool but
then loki as
db cooper the famous mystery man who
hijacked a plane in 1971 and then
parachuted out never to be found
in this timeline at least the answer to
that mystery was it's a loki
now last trailer loki jumped out saying
brother
i'm down you'd better be ready by
brother he's referring to his brother
thor
and loki is expected to appear in thor
love and thunder so it sounds like this
series will show exactly how loki
delivers on that promise to thor and
infinity war
i assure you brother the sun will shine
on us again
all right next clip you can trust me
okay i've studied almost every moment of
your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
why never do it again
i love this here in the tva cafeteria
they drink boku fruit juice
like bolivia's it's another random relic
from the past an adult fruit juice in a
12-ounce box
memorable for its 90s ads with comedian
richard lewis i want a boku
i've had it people invite me to a party
i'm bringing my own boat code can you
just imagine moby is saying
oh wow you never heard of boku it's the
best they never should have discontinued
it
wow and on to the last clip
yes finally loki stands with mobius in
the ancient city of pompeii
moments before it was destroyed by the
eruption of mount vesuvius we know it is
pompeii because
in the other trailer roman numerals were
visible reading lxxix
79 the year pompeii was destroyed so
fingers crossed loki's adventure here
sheds light on that mystery of the seder
square the palindromic relic found in
the ruins of pompeii that inspired
christopher nolan to make tenant we can
expect loki to be every bit as confusing
and new rock stars to be here waiting
for you with answers your savior has
arrived yes i am wearing our falcon and
winter soldier inspired anarchy
assembled shirt
in limited supply you can get it at our
merch store newrockstarsmerch.com
and by the way if you've been following
our weekly fitness origin series you
know that philip is putting tommy and me
through workouts as part of his fun mcu
themed fitness challenge the whole
experience has reminded me of the
importance of living a healthy life
which we want you to join in on i want
to be around a long time to make these
videos and i want you to be around to
watch them
no no i don't think i will
you can follow along and do the same
workouts tommy and i are doing over at
the epic hero fitness
channel subscribe to epic hero fitness
to follow our journey do the workouts
and catch some upcoming bloopers and
outtakes
sometimes the bloopers even sound like
blooper as they're coming out of my
butthole follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss follow me rockstar
subscribe to rockstars here on youtube
for breakdowns of everything you love
thank you for watching
and actually you want to take this one
loki
[Music]
you